one of the great mysteries that we all
hope to learn more about in 1o is the
creation of the pony lives and with the
clear focus on armament haki in this arc
I can't help but wonder if these at
first glance very different concepts
might not be connected in some way after
all
haki has become a central part of the
power system in one piece while we got
occasional clues in the first half of
the series about its existence it was
not until the two-year time skip that we
learned of this other superhuman
phenomenon in the one-piece world beside
the devil fruits but what exactly is
haki all the Japanese word haki carries
many meanings the one that probably
catches its nature best is willpower at
its core it is an extension of the will
into the physical world haki exists in
every living thing in the one-piece
world however most failed to awaken it
and usually are not even aware of its
existence since it is a physical
manifestation of will there is a certain
limit to how strong it is and for how
long it can be used as a consequence
haki can also be trained and improved
now in general there are two types of
haki that anyone can awaken on the right
circumstances and with the right
training the first of these two is
observation or Ken boon Shoku haki it
functions as an extension of other
natural senses by interacting with the
willful presence of other living things
depending on the level of training
observation haki allows its user to
detect the location and movement as well
as the emotions or intentions of a
person and in its very advanced form it
can even predict an action slightly to
the future by reading a person's will
before it is even translated into a
movement
the second form of hockey is armaments
or buso shakuhachi it gives the users
will a physical shape so far we've only
seen this in the form of hardening but
there seems to be more to it as we will
hopefully find out later on in this arc
still in principle depending on the
level of the user this hardening can
still be overcome by pure physical
strength or by another user with
stronger willpower
now while observation and armament haki
exist in every living thing there's a
third kind of haki that only a very
exclusive group of people have access to
conquerors or how Shoku haki can only be
awakened by those who have the will of a
conqueror it uses the strong will of the
user to directly influence the weaker
wills of others we have so far seen the
submission of will
in the form of taming intimidation as
well as knocking others unconscious it
is still mysterious though what the true
power of Congress hockey is and what
makes it so unique now as a consequence
the introduction of these three types of
willpower into the fighting system has
changed the power distribution in the
warm peace world significantly from our
perspective before hockey if you ate and
acquired the power of a devil fruit it
gave the person a clear advantage over
normal people
after the time-skip though we learned
that hockey can be used to actively
counter devil fruit users this allowed
people without a power to compete at the
top level as well in a way hockey has
led to a shift from supernatural power
to individual skill and training when it
comes to fights on a very high level you
could even argue that especially in the
New World
having strong hockey might actually be
way more important than owning a devil
fruit power still there is a lot we do
not know about the concept of hockey
while we now know a lot about
observation haki conquers hockey remains
mostly mystery but we recently learned a
little more about the functioning of
armament haki from yukimaru he explained
to us that sorrow sword shoots we turned
black over a certain period of time in
the hands of Reema the hero of guano and
it seems to be very likely that this is
connected to the use of hockey but how
exactly does this infusion of objects
with hockey work in the first place and
how could it be connected to the
creation of the poni glyphs infusing an
object with armament haki basically
refers to transferring and manifesting
one's willpower onto its surface so far
we have only seen three different types
of hockey and fusion in the story the
first and most common use of armament is
to coat parts of the users own body or
anything in contact with it this seems
to be the most basic form of hockey in
fusion that has to be achieved by anyone
who wants to call themselves a true
armament user the coding of willpower
hardens the skin and gives it increased
attack and defense in terms of physical
combat additionally it also serves as a
weapon against delaford users since the
use of hockey is able to nullify a devil
fruits power now this effect can also be
extended to any object that is in
contact with the body since it allows a
direct flow of willpower we most
commonly see this happening with swords
or clothing but what does this actually
do so for instance when sorrow coats has
soared into hockey it increases the
level of hardness significantly make
it's stronger and less likely to break
once he loses hold of his weapons though
the flow of hockey stops and the Blake
goes back to normal and this brings us
to the second type of use in fusing
armament into objects for a short amount
of time without actually keeping direct
contact now as we just saw with the
example of Zorro usually the flow of
hockey stops when object loses contact
with the user's body yet we have
actually seen an example where this was
not the case when luffy was sent to
amazon lille by kuma the Kuja tribe of
the island actually had the ability to
infuse the arrows with hockey which made
them ridiculously strong and effective
while this is the only case where we
have seen this ability officially in the
story so far
it proves that hockey can be stored
inside an object for a certain amount of
time even without keeping contact to
achieve this I believe special training
will be required and I would not be
surprised to be introduced to variations
of this like hockey infuse bullets in
the near future in the story
why else for instance what Keys aru be
threatened by Ben Backman pointed gun at
him but that is another question now the
real question here is whether objects
can also be infused with hockey over a
longer amount of time which brings us to
the third type of armament use permanent
hockey in fusion and this also brings us
back to our good friend yukimaru who
suggested to us that shoe sweet turned
into a black blade over time a frequent
use through a mighty swordsman if this
actually ties back to repeated infusion
of a blade with hockey that will mean
that it is possible to permanently store
your willpower in an object where in
other words making it permanently coated
in armament and while we have only seen
this technique being used with weapons
so far I do not see any reason why this
should not be possible with any other
object as well so let's think are there
any other objects in the one-piece world
that seem to display these distinct
traits of hockey in fusion and the
answer to this unnecessarily dramatic
rhetorical question is yes poni glyphs
actually seem to fit perfectly into this
category so let's take a look at what
poni glyphs actually are and why they
might be hockey made 800 years ago in
one Oh a clan of master stonemasons
known as the Kisuke family created
indestructible stone blocks that
recorded important historical events
from the white century these stone
blocks would become known as the pony
glyphs physically Pony lists are massive
cube shaped rocks made of an apparently
indestructible
stone that carry ancient text on their
surface the creators that Kazuki family
passed on the knowledge of how to read
and write these ancient letters within
their family up until Kazuki Odom due to
his execution though he couldn't pass on
his knowledge making robbing the
survival of Ahura the last person in the
world capable of deciphering these
ancient symbols in total there are three
types of Kona glyphs scattered across
the world historical Pony glyphs
instructional Pony glyphs and wrote Pony
glyphs historical Pony glyphs contain
pieces of ancient history during the
void century instructional Pony glyphs
contain information about the location
of these historical Pony glyphs and
finally the four road Pony lives
together detail the location of rough
tell the final island of the grand line
that contains the legendary one piece
now I think that it's fair to say that
the pony lives are of incredible
importance they carry the secret of the
ancient kingdom and the void century
through the ages without the world
government being able to destroy them
what then made these blocks of stone
survived for over 900 years unscratched
was it the material they were made out
of and then how in the world whether
Kisuke able to write on them a much
likely answer is that the Pony glyphs
are actually haki infused objects let's
look at the arguments for this the first
and most obvious clue we have is the
indestructibility and agelessness of the
pony glyphs just like the black blades
we talked about earlier they appear to
be unbreakable
also similar like a black blade would
never rusts the rock that they are made
out of never shows any sign of erosion
or cracking they're simply perfect cubes
preserved in time having them
permanently coated in hockey would
definitely explain this phenomenon the
second argument is the existence of
devil fruits now I would argue that it
is 100% certain that more than one
person at some point in time tried to
destroy opponent lifts with his devil
fruit power and we have seen the
destructive power of some of these
fruits if you imagine someone wielding a
power like white clears guru guru Nomi
it seems highly unlikely that any type
of rock no matter how special could
withstand such forces with the pony
lives covered in hockey though the whole
situation would look completely
different
the nullifying powers of haki would
explain why no devil threw power no
matter how strong would ever be able to
put even as much as a scratch on the
stone surface since it would be
nullified on contact
the third clue is the mystery around the
voices of all things
Goldie Roger was able to sense the
content of the Pony glyphs without
actually being able to read them now
while this indeed could be a completely
new and unrelated power would it not
make so much more sense if Roger was
actually able to interpret the will that
was poured into the creation of this
stone the importance and urgency that
was used to create this record of
ancient history would have been
imprinted on the stone itself the
ability to hear the voices of all things
might in the end simply be an even more
unique form of hockey that allows the
user to interpret a beings will on a
completely different level having an
object that is filled to the brim with
willpower carrying a message of great
emotional and historic importance would
definitely radiate what was engraved in
it lastly we can take a look at the
color scheme of the poni glyphs now I'm
well aware that this argument can be
seen as a little bit controversial but
bear with me here
regular Pony glyphs have a dark bluish
to black coloring that gives them their
mysterious appearance this dark coating
definitely resembles the coloring that
we can see in other instances of our
limit hockey being used the road Pony
glyphs on the other hand are red this
special type of coloring and armament
can be seen when strong enough hockey's
being used luffy's gear forth has a
similar red glow to it Virgo and pica
were purple and karakuri had a blue glow
surrounding him additionally we know
that stronger haki takes on distinct
shapes like the flame patterns that we
can see with Luffy or Big Mama the red
color scheme of the road Pony glyphs
might also be related to the red we see
displayed when two uses of conquerors
haki clash now while it might be easy to
say that the Pony glyphs color scheme is
related to that of armament haki I'm
well aware of the fact that the color
aspect of hockey is still a little bit
controversial
it is not clear in many cases if it is a
design choice or intentional yet we know
that the kanji for color is explicitly
part of the full description for hockey
and is being used in the manga as well
in my opinion since armament can also be
translated as the color of arms it might
very well serve as a legitimate fourth
argument here all in all I think that
the theory that the Pony glyphs are made
using haki infusion has some very solid
arguments that would explain a lot of
the mystery surrounding them and it
would also bring even more importance to
the role of armament haki in this arc
now as a conclusion I would like to give
you guys a few questions to ponder upon
off
watching this video do you think he
could break a pony glyph was strong
enough haki how many people would have
worked on creating a pony to live in the
first place and how good were they with
hockey what other objects might be
infused with hockey in the one-piece
world and finally do you have any
additional arguments for or against his
theory share your thoughts and ideas in
the comments below if you like this
video don't forget to like share and
subscribe to be notified for any future
content of mine or dislike don't share
and unsubscribe it's a free world people
I hope to see you around next time and
until then have a great week
you
[Music]